e
avec Carla Oliveira.
(vrombissement)
- And lift off of Artemis 1!
- 25 j s s se sont écoulés
depuis le décollage de la fusée
SLS et la capsule Orion.
Un voyage autour de la Lune
très satisfaisant p
les reponsables de la NASA.
Mais le vrai test pour Orion
était le retour dans
l'atmosphère terrestre
avec une nouvelle manoeuvre.
OLIVIER HERNANDEZ, directeur,
Planétarium Rio Tinto Alcan
- On a joué sur le fait
qu'on a fait un premier rebond
sur l'atmosphère pour freiner
tout doucement la capsule,
puis ensuite entrer directement
dans l'atmosphère terrestre,
ce que l'on ne fait pas
par exemple pour des capsules
qui reviennent de la Station
spatiale internationale.
- Entry inner phase has begun.
- Les parois du vaisseau spati
doivent résister à 2800 °C.
Un bouclier thermique de
5 mètres de diamètre, le plus
gros jamais construit, assure
la protection de la cae.e.e.
Son bon fonctionnement garantit
l'avenir du programme Artemis.
- La Lune aurait un rôle
important à jouer pour le futur
de l'exploration spatiale,
d'abord pour servir de base de
relais vers d'autres planètes,
comme la planète Mars.
- Splashdown.
- Deux heures devaient
s'écouler avant le repêchage
et le remorquage de la capsule
Orion pour permettre la collecte
de données sur l'état du
vaisseau, qui s'est aventuré
dans l'espace à plus de
430 000 km de la Terre.
C'est l'équipage spécialisé
du USS Portland, un navire de
la Marine américaine positionné
au large de la Basse-Californie
depuis samedi, qui est chargé
de récupérer la capsule
des eaux du Pacifique.
- Three, two, one...
Ignition, liftoff.
- Le 11 décembre semble être
une date de prédilection pour
les événements d'exploration
spatiale. Une fusée de SpaceX
décollait aujourd'hui
à Cap Canaveral pour lancer
un alunisseur de l'entreprise
japonaise ispace.
Cette compagnie privée vise
l'exploration robotique à faible
coût et a conçu un alunisseur
qui consomme moins de carburant.
Deux entreprises canadiennes
profiteront de cette mission
pour tester la résistance de
leur technologie sur la Lune.
ISABELLE TREMBLAY, Agence
spatiale canadienne
- Ce sont les entreprises,
vraiment entre elles,
qui ont transigé et ça,
c'est ce qu'on va voir
de plus en plus à l'avenir,
avec la commercailisation,
avec les coûts de l'accès à
l'espace, qui diminuent.
- Et puis, il y a 50 ans,
les astronautes de la mission
Apollo 17 marchaient sur
la Lune. Ce sont les dernier